I'm not really content creatively unless
I'm doing something that scares me a
little bit it's just the more you know
about what's possible and how to do it
the more freedom you have whatever if it
makes you laugh it's it's an honest
laughs we're going through a bit of a
dark ages as far as FCC restrictions and
what we cause a lot we can't do now that
we used to be able to do when the show
started he's an American TV producer
filmmaker actor and singer he's best
known as the creator of the TV series
Family Guy his first feature-length film
Ted became the highest-grossing original
r-rated comedy he's Seth MacFarlane and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number one is my personal
favorite I make sure to stick around all
the way to the end for a special bonus
clip and as always as Seth is talking if
he says something that really resonates
with you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
what were you like as a child um I I was
a combination of reclusive and obsessed
with what I wanted to do when I was 2 I
want I was sitting in front of the TV
drawing Fred Flintstone's and woody
woodpecker's and at age seven I'm
running around like a crazy person doing
voices but at the same time I would try
to make animated films and try to figure
out exactly how that art form worked
when did you do your first cartoon how
old were you and what was it I was in
seventh grade it was called space
pirates it was terrible
I like your bustle by the way oh yeah I
really love that the most alluring
fashion statement a woman can make today
is to simulate effect is a simulation of
a fad right there we don't often see you
in front of the camera so what made you
think this time all right here we go
throughout the course of my career I've
managed to continue to challenge myself
and to try things that I haven't tried
and to keep scaring myself I'm not
really content creatively unless I'm
doing something that scares me a little
bit but stimulating there's something
inside you that keeps saying no go
further try something different it's a
it's a constant crippling feeling of
inadequacy what is yeah we spoke to your
dad at the premiere last night and
here's what he said I just have such
great respect for him and he's still a
very very grounded and kind and focused
human being he's a good soul a good
person and that's more than anything
else what I'm proud of my dad's such it
I'm gonna get him for that man oh man
I'm gonna go yes from start to finish it
takes about nine months to sometimes
longer sometimes you know ten months
it's roughly a year between the time
that the story is pitched the time it
gets on the air takes roughly a year to
do it and it's you know no one has ever
figured out a quicker way to do
hand-drawn animation
in primetime and it's all still
hand-drawn it's colored with computers
but every single frame is still done by
hand you know the season is a little
smoother than last season last season
was a little smoother than the one
before so it's it's it gets incremental
easier it's still in many ways a seven
day a week job to get this thing done I
mean it's it's it's a virtually
impossible thing to do a prime time
animated series yet somehow there's a
bunch of people that do it I you know I
it's it's I don't know how the The
Simpsons you know does it for as long as
they they've been doing it but it's it's
a it's a it's just a very very intense
process that just in many ways gets
easier when you get cancelled what
advice can you give to someone who wants
to study animation there's a million
ways to do it it's it's it's trial and
error with me it was just trial and
error it's just it was it was it's it's
learning the it is learning the the
process you do have to find a good
school I mean that's the best thing you
can do Rhode Island School of Design was
great Cal arts is great I mean that
there's there's there's a lot of art
schools that now have gotten up to date
with their animation programs but it's
just doing it it's just doing as much of
it as you can and sitting you know even
if it's in what with one of those little
cheap video camera things just
experimenting with movement and
experimenting with speeds of movement
and what looks funny it's just the more
you know about what's possible and how
to do it the more freedom you have to
it's like it's the same as directing I
guess it's the same as I just gotta go
out and do that yeah if you know what is
possible and what you're capable of then
you know learn your tools for yeah yeah
and how they work yeah and at 24 he
became the youngest person to ever head
a network show haha that led to the
spin-offs The Cleveland Show
air here Stan box
don't get kidnapped and American Dad ah
you're off me yeah that's what your mom
said last night that doesn't seem to be
anything off limits I made a little list
of some of the things that you discuss
bestiality abortion age Irishman who
drink nuns premature ejaculation
breastfeeding and Fox yeah easy for me
to say all that when you line it all up
like that I mean it sounds like maybe
we've made a huge mistake come on you
know what I am back at the ranch I'm a
breeding bull well what's yak you gonna
find out the trick to getting it all
past the census according to Seth is not
to offend too many groups in any given
episode it all just can't be in the same
place there's something called tonnage
and we try to we try to keep those jokes
spread apart it is a balance but my view
is that whatever if it makes you laugh
it's it's an honest laugh push the
envelope a lot yes obviously you do have
you has there ever been something that's
like oh god it's no to this even for us
we can't do that um yeah yeah I mean
there's there's the occasional uh God
joke about it's too racist or too you
know offensive to people with a
particular disease or you know there's
too much abortion centric comedy that we
say you know probably that shouldn't go
you know this is just three examples
that come to mind probably that that
maybe shouldn't go in the show maybe
just for the DVD but we do that there
are things that we do now that we do
strictly for and we do a few versions of
the show there's one for television and
then there's one for the DVD because
it's it's a very you know it's it's it's
it's a we're going through a bit of a
dark ages as far as FCC restrictions and
what week is a lot we can't do now that
we used to be able to do when the show
started and so to kind of fight that we
do DVD versions in which you know you
can kind of see the show
untouched okay here's one if you were
gay and you had to have sex with either
John Forsythe or Sean Connery who would
it be
yeah it's so funny I would also say John
Forsythe that was just curious you know
there are great things about television
and there are great things about film
television has the advantage of speed
you can conceive an idea and see it
through to fruition all in the time
frame that you're just getting a movie
off the ground you can tell different
types of stories every week and if one
of them is you know you can experiment a
little more one of them goes wrong well
there's always next week with them with
a movie you know the flip side of that
is you can the one story that you tell
you can really get it right so it
depends on the project generally the
idea comes first if I have an idea then
I sort of think to myself was this
better as a series or as a feature and I
think that's you know I think that's a
good way to do it you you're slaving
away six months slaving away because
you're actually pursuing a dream and
it's it's incredibly hard work but also
I'm guessing kind of feels like Jesus
this is kind of it and I've really got a
I do have to pour everything I have into
this yeah I mean that you know they they
they had given me you know each other
the life of Larry you're talking about
well do the pilot for Fox yeah yeah that
woman they gave me something like forty
thousand dollars to do this animated
pilot usually you know it's about
anywhere from 800,000 to a million to do
an animate a pilot so right and I've
just said yes I can do it and I'll
figure out how to do it after the fact
and you did yeah yeah yeah and it's it's
it's kind of thing where it's it's it's
such it was it was a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity right where they're
basically saying you know we'll give you
a small amount of money you're basic
enough to kill yourself for half a year
but if you if it works then you're set
and you know you've gotten in right and
so it was a gamble but it I've managed
to manage to do it you try to stay
timely let's read the Paris Hilton thing
today would you ever move into that area
um yeah you know it's possible it's it's
it's I mean it's tough it's tough with
things that are that are very very
immediate because of the fact that it
does take us a year to do these things
you know if we do you know we did a joke
about when Ashley Simpson had the lip
synching business on Saturday Night Live
we did a joke on that and we were by the
time it aired we were just on the tail
end of relevance because it had already
many months had passed and you know it I
think that's a good thing though because
I think it's a good thing for longevity
I think it's a good thing for reruns if
you look at excuse me if you look at all
in the family you know that's a show
that was very very topical and very much
of its time but it was general enough
that you can watch it now and not have
to know what was going on that specific
week with Richard Nixon you can still
enjoy it now that's sort of the balance
that we like to we like to go for all
right guys the best thing you can do for
your body after a massage is hot coffee
alcohol and slim jims you could be an
impressionist I mean you could if you
wanted to make your light living as you
know traveling rich riffing there are
there are many times at a table read
that we write it write a piece for
somebody and want to get a guest star
and Seth will fill in and do it or Seth
Green wheel or I will and nine times out
of ten
McFarland's read for whoever is way
funnier than when we actually book the
person
and many times he'll end up recording
else can he do that we will be very
amenable to here really bet he'll who
permit Kermit wrong Kermit the Frog did
that take him thing say that we have a
gag we have a gag I'm shocked I'm a gym
Henson's taken yeah I know I don't have
any money but when I do have for a
certain set of skills
[Music]
tells it could be a nightmare for
someone like you
[Music]
if you don't let the girl go I will
track you down I will find you
I will kill you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Gerardo asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what did Seth say
that really resonated with you leave in
the comments really curious to find out
finally want to give a quick shout out
to Shahrukh thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book and posting
that tweet about it I really really
really appreciate it and I hope you
enjoy so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
all right well we have got work to do so
let's roll up our sleeves and get right
to it there's a lot to do so we can't be
afraid to just roll up our sleeves and
get the job done we can't be hands-off
managers we gotta roll up our sleeves
and just dig in Peter your arms are
turning purple purple with success
that's the color of money you got to do
to work a 2-man and pay yourself for one
just roll up those sleeves and address
the task at hand whatever it may be not
shying away from the dirty work but just
rolling up our sleeves and haven't had
it success is not given it is taken it's
time to get in the game and get dirty
all right I'm going to lunch